how would you compare
so it seems like elon musk is more
engineering
centric but it's also i think he
considers himself a designer too
he has a design mind steve jobs feels
like he is
much more idea space design space versus
engineering yeah just make it happen
like the world should be this way just
figure it out but
but he used computers you know he had
computer people talk to him all the time
like mike was a really good computer guy
he knew what computers could do
computer meaning computer hardware like
hardware software all of pieces the
whole thing
and then he would you know have an idea
about what could we do with this
next that was grounded in reality it
wasn't like he was you know just
finger painting on the wall and wishing
somebody would interpret it
like so he had this interesting
connection because
you know he wasn't a computer architect
a designer
but he had an intuition from the
computers we had to what could happen
and essentially you say intuition
because
it seems like he was pissing off a lot
of engineers
in his intuition about what can and
can't be done
those like the what is all these stories
about like floppy disks and all that
kind of stuff like
yeah so in in steve the first round like
he'd go into a lab
and look at what's going on and hate it
and and uh
fire people or ask somebody in the
elevator what they're doing for apple
and you know not be happy when he came
back my impression was
is he surrounded himself with this
relatively small group of people
yes and didn't really interact outside
of that as much
and then the joke was you'd see like a
little somebody moving a prototype
through the
quad with a with a black blanket over it
and that was because it was secret
you know partly from steve because they
didn't want steve to see it until it was
ready
yeah the dynamic with johnny ive and
steve
is interesting it's like you don't want
to
he ruins as many ideas as he generates
yeah
yeah it's a dangerous kind of wanting to
walk
if you have a lot of ideas like like
gordon bell was famous for ideas
right and it wasn't that the percentage
of good ideas was way higher than
anybody else
it was he had so many ideas and and he
was also good at talking people about
it and and getting the filters right and
you know seeing through stuff whereas
elon was like hey i want to build
rockets
so steve would hire a bunch of rocket
guys and elon would go read rocket
manuals
so ian is a better engineer a sense like
or
like more uh like a love and passion for
the manuals
and the details the details the
craftsmanship too right
well i guess you had craftsmanship too
but of a different kind
you